تخيل مغادرة منزلك أو فندقك لمدة
ساعتين في واحدة من
أجمل الأماكن في الولايات المتحدة.  مثل
Steamboat Springs Colorado ، ما
لا تفكر فيه هو أنك قد تجد
نفسك مرتبكًا أو حتى
تائهًا وقد ينتهي بك الأمر بقضاء الليل
هناك ، ما أحضرته معك في
حقيبة الظهر الخاصة بك يمكن أن ينقذ حياتك
نحن مع داريل ليفينسون  البحث عن طريق
المقاطعة وإنقاذها وأنت تعرف عن
كثب مدى خطورة ذلك في
الجبال خاصة إذا لم تكن من
هنا وتحاول الذهاب في نزهة
وربما تغير الطقس أو
تضيع في
أي وقت تغامر فيه
يجب أن تكون مستعدًا لقضاء
الليل ، فما هي اقتراحاتك
للأشياء التي يجب أن تحضرها معك دائمًا
في حقيبة الظهر الخاصة بك عندما تخرج في أي وقت
أذهب فيه للتزلج بالأحذية الثلجية أو إذا كنت تعلم
التزلج عبر الريف ، سأقوم دائمًا
بحمل هذا في  الحبل الذي يمكنني وضعه
حول رقبتي به صافرة
لأن الصافرة ستحمل مسافة أكبر
في الغابة ، ثم صوتك في بعض
المباريات المقاومة للماء أيضًا إذا
انفصلت عن حقيبتي وهذا كل ما
لدي  n البقاء على قيد الحياة ، فإن القدرة على
إشعال حريق ربما تكون أهم
شيء يمكنك القيام به على الأقل من طريقتين إلى
ثلاث طرق لبدء رياح حريق
ومباريات مقاومة للماء ولاعة
ومعقم لليدين ، صب مطهر اليدين مباشرة
على جميع العصي واشعله فقط
عنصر آخر يجب على الجميع حمله هو
بوصلة ، يمكنك فقط تدوين ملاحظة سريعة إذا
كنت متجهًا غربًا وإذا
شعرت بالارتباك في وقت ما ، فأقل
ما يمكنك فعله هو استخدام البوصلة الخاصة بك والتوجه الآن
شرقًا ونأمل أن تعود إلى
طريق  بالطبع ، الطعام والماء ، الماء
هو أهم شيء يمكنك الذهاب إليه
لأيام في كل مرة بدون طعام ولكنك
لن تستمر طويلاً بدون
ماء ، احمل مجموعة صغيرة من الإسعافات الأولية
والمضادات الحيوية مرهم بعض الضمادات
التي يمكن أن تصنعها
الفرق ، قبعة إضافية وزوج من القفازات ،
معطف واق من المطر ومعطف إضافي
للراحة ، أهم شيء وقبل أن
تذهب إلى الغابة هو إخبار شخص ما إلى
أين أنت ذاهب ومتى
ستعود يمكن للناس  يكون  العثور عليها
بسرعة كبيرة والعودة إلى المنزل وليس لديك
لقضاء تلك الليلة
بالكلمات